[Musique]
bonjour monsieur m'a flers tu dis jamais
merci toi jamais ya deux erreurs
comment est ce que vous allez vous
reposer je me reposerai quand je serai
mort
monsieur t on monsieur chinoise elle
savoir mon père a fait un avc
écoutez c'est pas forcément d'armes ne
semble pas de la nuit verte
pour la nuit maire de la samba quant à
vis des blocs en fait c'est la zone du
langage et de la mémoire qui ont été
touchés on va faire quelques tests liés
aux trolls mardi mercanti bon rassure
toi rien de sortie dans la presse quand
je te laisse faut que j'aille voir la
psychopathe
quand vous souvenez pas d'un mot essayé
pendant deux mois un cheval qui courent
on dit qu'il [ __ ] presque vous sentez
comment aujourd'hui je veux mark hurd
ici bonjour vous avez l'air en pleine
forme de revoir madame
vous faites tout pour que je vous êtes
vous et une fois vous avez ce que vous
voulez puis une nouvelle ça fait trois
ans que je me tape des études pour
quinze jours de sainté reste un tout
petit peu à moins ne sert pas des gens
comme ça ça fait pas son coup je suis
tout vu
j'ai besoin des deux vitrines et c'est
pas possible mais vous êtes sérieux là
quel siège de pienaar bon c'est quand
même super à partir de maintenant ça
c'est ta mémoire et là c'est la maison
et ça c'est toi comme tu veux plus
perdre bercy merci monsieur athée et à
ces cas
ok
[Musique]